new intelligence update from the UK
Ministry of Defense says Russia is
likely to have increased its armored
assaults around the town of marinka in
eastern Ukraine in the last week which
has been fought over since 2014 of
course well let's bring in our military
analyst retired Air Vice Marshall Sean
Bell
um Sean let's talk first of all and give
give our viewers an idea of the
situation on the ground as it stands
right now in Ukraine the fighting
continues across a whole 1200 kilometer
front line as you say marinka has been a
particularly interesting death down to
the South there the Russians conducting
an armored assault there but it's worth
pointing out as you say they've been
fighting there since 2014 and the
Russians have in nine years have made
just over two kilometers progress so
it's painfully slow the progress the
other areas of Ditka and bakmut up to
the north again there's been a dozens of
attacks over the last 24 hours there but
the rate of attacks is definitely
diminishing the Russian offensive is
definitely losing momentum a couple of
other some news were interesting the
wagon group if you remember yevgeni
pragosan who ran that was getting a bit
too influential so the Russians stopped
him recruiting convicts to bolster his
military but President Putin probably
recognizes that Russian Society probably
cares less about convicts losing their
lives than their very own conscripts so
the Russian mod the Russian army is now
recruiting convicts itself trying to put
them under 18 month contracts an
interesting development and also Russian
concerns about the impact of Western
Battle Tanks supporting Ukraine when
their offensive starts the Russians are
now under a bonus scheme where if they
are able to damage or destroy a NATO
provision tank they will be uh be
financially recompensed so we'll be
expect to hear a lot more of this in the
media as it plays out once the Ukrainian
offensive starts interesting moves from
president who's in there well let's zoom
out a bit and um I understand the
Russian defense minister is visiting
Belarus why do you think that is Sergo
shogu is today visiting Belarus so it's
a face value you understand this is
because Belarus is seeking security
guarantees because it's worried that if
he does get attacked will Russia come to
its Aid the trouble is if you look
behind the scenes here first of all
Ukraine has neither the military
capability nor the intent to actually
start to take on Belarus and NATO is a
defensive organization so it's very
difficult to see where the threat
actually lies and almost certainly this
is about Russian political control the
Russians have used military force to
take or try to take Ukraine they're
using political force to try to take
Belarus and we're seeing the two uh
obviously sure guy in his military
uniform and president lukashenko's sat
there
um the Russians have been doing military
training in Belarus they've been basing
military aircraft there they've been
basing tactical nuclear weapons there
now they're talking about providing
security guarantees all of this is
putting more and more Russian soldiers
onto Belarusian soil it's basically it's
a former Russian invasion but by stealth
okay now I want to get your take on the
fact that uh some classified U.S
documents have been released what do you
make of that Sean yeah the news was
breaking over the last week of over 100
U.S documents appeared on the internet
some of them marked as top secret They
Carried a whole load of information
about Ukrainian capability the redness
States the impact Western weapons the
state of the weather how that might
impact the war et cetera
um but what's worth putting into context
here is the West normally uh embeds the
media in with the military that's not
the case because we're not directly
involved in the War uh this time around
so what the US and UK are trying to do
is to declassify classify information so
it can get it out to the media to help
inform that and most of the information
that appears in most of these documents
isn't in itself secret what's secret is
the way that information was found so
for example how many Russian tanks are
available on the battlefield today that
number is interesting but it's not
particularly secret but how you find out
how many there were that becomes much
more sensitive tip so release leaks of
documents and data like this whilst it's
interesting it's the the authorities
will be less concerned with the actual
data that's out there but more concerned
about the sources of that data than the
need to preserve those yeah absolutely
um I've retired advice Marshall Sean
Bell thanks very much indeed